So, jetzt muss ich die richtige Auflösung haben.
Auf Twitch, krieg dich ein und starte das Teil.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob ich die richtige Auflösung habe.
Ja, jetzt hat es 1080p.
So, wunderbar.
Also, das ist jetzt eine spontane Sache.
Ich wollte mir gerade das neue Ubuntu angucken.
Also, das, was quasi in einem Monat rauskommt.
17.10.
Und das kommt zum ersten Mal
mit einem neuen Display-Server raus.
Und ich dachte mir, ich probiere das mal aus.
Und ich habe gerade auf Twitter gefragt,
ob ich das streamen soll.
Und da haben überraschend viele Leute geschrieben,
ja, habe ich mir gedacht,
dann streben wir das jetzt.
Vielleicht ein bisschen unglückliche Zeit,
14.40 Uhr montags,
da werden auch einige Leute auf der Arbeit sein.
Ja.
Aber gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Das kann aber auch sein,
das ist relativ schnell.
Vorbei ist, weil, wie gesagt,
das ist noch einen Monat hin,
bis das rauskommt.
Und vielleicht ist das Daily-Build so verbuggt,
dass wir es überhaupt nicht installiert bekommen.
0.3.D.
Moin, Philna.
Und auch das Imperatorchen.
Rox Twitchmason,
Silentpain, Alexliebkekse
und xFatal.
Tatsache.
Gut.
Dann fangen wir mal an.
Ich bin ja begeistert,
wie viele Leute schon da sind um 14.40 Uhr montags.
Lull.
So, also wir fangen mal an.
Also, nochmal zur Erklärung,
vielleicht für die, die gerade eingeschaltet haben.
Hallo, Evoli.
Wir gucken uns mal das neue Ubuntu an,
was in einem Monat rauskommt.
Und
wieso der neue Display-Server ist.
Also traditionell ist es ja so,
dass
ähm
Linux mit X-Org läuft,
also spricht für die grafische Oberfläche.
Ich meine damit nicht,
ähm
den Desktop an sich,
oder hier irgendwie Fenster rumschieben oder so,
auch wenn das jetzt Windows ist,
sondern quasi so die Schnittstelle zwischen,
sagen wir es mal ganz grob,
zwischen
Grafikkartentreiber
und Desktop.
Ich glaube, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut, was ein Display-Server ist.
Und ähm
ähm
standardmäßig verwendet Linux schon seit
einer ganzen Weile X-Org
und jetzt der neueste Schrei ist allerdings Wayland.
Und äh
Ubuntu
beziehungsweise Canonical,
die sind die, die Hersteller von Ubuntu,
waren der Meinung, sie machen da nicht mit und bauen irgendwas eigenes.
Und
glücklicherweise, ich glaube die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, ne?
Machen wir mal eben hier ein bisschen leiser.
So.
Und
jetzt mit dem neuen Ubuntu,
was in einem Monat rauskommt,
hat sich allerdings Canonical auch dazu entschlossen,
sie scheißen auf, wir machen was eigenes,
sondern nehmen Wayland.
Ubuntu hat die ganze Zeit,
das haben die an mir rumgebaut.
Das ist so eine eigene Sache gewesen von Ubuntu.
Allerdings jetzt haben sie gesagt,
okay, wir nehmen das,
was alle anderen auch nehmen,
wir nehmen Wayland.
Und Ubuntu 17.10 ist die erste Version.
Ist die erste Version,
die quasi jetzt mit Wayland rauskommt
und mit
nicht mehr diesem
komischen Unity-Desktop.
Mit Unity ist in dem Fall nicht die Game Engine gemeint,
sondern
äh
Ubuntu Unity.
Der hässlichste Desktop aller Zeiten.
Das war so...
Ich krieg schon Augenkrebs, wenn ich das sehe.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So Instant-Kotz-Reflex, wenn ich Unity sehe.
Also, den Desktop.
Bei der Engine kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten,
aber der Unity-Desktop sieht wirklich kacke aus.
So, und jetzt ist Ubuntu für 17.10 auch umgeschwenkt auf...
Ja, übrigens hier Patrick,
die Farbgebung ist immer noch die gleiche unter 17.10.
Allerdings ist es dann unter dem neuen Ubuntu,
ist es wie gesagt Wayland als Display-Server
und Gnome 3 als Desktop.
Allerdings wieder mit dieser tollen Ubuntu-Farbgebung.
So.
Da müssen wir den ganzen Cram-Tool jetzt mal runterladen.
Gibt's das denn?
Daily.
Da.
Daily Build.
Im aktuellen Ubuntu.
Wohlgemerkt, ähm, Ubuntu 17.10 Release.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen, bis das offiziell rauskommt.
Also, das ist noch für Ubuntu-Verhältnisse
ziemlich früh in der Entwicklung.
Ähm.
Am 31. August
gab's die Beta 1.
Äh, in ein paar Tagen gibt's, ähm,
die letzte Beta-Version.
Und erst quasi ungefähr in vier Wochen
kommt dann das finale Ubuntu 17.10 raus.
Also, das ist für Ubuntu noch relativ früh
und es kann sein, dass das jetzt überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Was? Why lul and not lol?
Ich wusste gar nicht mehr, dass man sich zwischen...
zwischen lul und lol noch entscheidet.
Ich dachte, es geht eher darum,
ob lul oder lul.
Also sprich, ob...
ob lul oder mit kleinem l.
Wobei ich ja der Meinung bin, dass
lul größer lol ist.
Genauso, wie es Alex gerade schreibt.
Ist gerade geklingelt? Nee, oder?
So, ähm.
Lass uns mal das aktuelle Ubuntu-Desktop runter.
Also sprich, das ist jetzt Midwayland und...
Gnome 3.
Oh, das ist ja höchst, höchst, höchst...
Highspeed hier.
Oh, geht doch.
Hat nur eine Weile gedauert, bis es anfängt.
So, dann können wir schon mal, machen wir hier OBS.
Minimieren wir das mal.
Hat es wieder geklingelt?
Warte, Moment.
Hört ihr es klingeln? Hat es geklingelt?
Ich höre das nämlich nicht mit meinem Headset auf.
Habt ihr das irgendwie gehört, ob es geklingelt hat?
Hat es gerade so angehört?
Hm.
Naja.
In der Zeit, wo das runter lädt, können wir schon mal
unsere VM anlegen.
So.
Habe ich hier natürlich auf Streaming-Account
noch nichts angelegt bisher.
Ich habe was gehört.
Du hörst, du bist doch gerade auf der Arbeit.
Du dürftest da eigentlich gar nichts hören.
Stimmt, stimmt. Guck mal.
Warum habe ich denn überhaupt noch die Battlefield 1 Open Beta?
Ich habe doch Battlefield 1 gar nicht.
Oder hat mir das EA gesponsert?
Irgendwann mal.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich dachte, ich habe Battlefield 1 gar nicht.
Aber ich hatte die Battlefield 1 Open Beta.
Was auch sonst alles.
Warum ich es noch inszeniert habe, keine Ahnung.
Sgt. sagt Falte,
dass Sway ist quasi
E3, richtig?
Deswegen will ich das auch ausprobieren.
Allerdings
für Wayland.
E3 hat keine Ambition, haben sie gesagt,
Wayland zu supporten.
Und nachdem ich ja E3-Fan bin,
bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig.
In Zukunft wahrscheinlich
Sway zu verwenden.
So, jetzt legen wir mal unsere VM an.
Installer Disk.
Das können wir nachher erst auswählen,
wenn es runtergeladen ist.
Wir wollen Ubuntu 64-bit.
Eigentlich wollen wir alles Default haben.
Wie viel Festplattenplatz haben wir noch?
Mal gucken.
Ja, es reicht.
Weißt du, wie schweineteuer der Scheiß gewesen ist?
Weißt du, wie
scheißteuer eine 2TB SSD ist?
Ich weiß auch nicht,
was mich da geritten hat, sowas zu kaufen.
Machen wir mal so.
Zwei Kerne.
Nicht 84,
2048. 42 GB RAM zum Testen
sollten ausreichen.
Alternativ. Wir können auch.
Wie viel habe ich denn hier eigentlich drinne? 0.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie viel RAM ich habe.
16, ok. Ah, komm, dann gehen wir
mal auf 1096.
Nicht das, was wir brauchen würden.
Bridge Network ist ok.
Wir wollen uns da per ssh
drauf verbinden können.
Und das funktioniert hier mit nut nicht
gescheit.
Not available.
Wir nehmen
das.
Gut.
Einfach alles Default. Create new Disk.
Alles in einem Disk-File.
Machen wir mal
30 GB. Man kann nie
genug Speicher haben.
Finish. Gut, der Download ist auch fertig.
Dann hängen
wir mal
das neue Ubuntu da dran.
Download. Artful.
Übrigens der Name wieder geil.
Neue
Ubuntu heißt, wo steht es denn überhaupt?
Artful
Artwag, falls man das
so ausspricht.
Ich vermute mal,
dass sie jetzt einfach
wieder bei A anfangen.
Nachdem sie ja
mit 1704 bei Z quasi
aufgehört haben.
Was ziemlich unkreativ ist, muss ich mal ehrlich sagen.
Ich dachte, die lassen sich jetzt da vielleicht mal irgendwie
ne lustigere Benahmung einfallen.
So, ähm, Installer
ausgesagt, anmachen.
Gucken wir mal. So, ähm, ich mach das mal
groß. Was?
Hm.
Was will er von mir?
Ich will nicht ein-
und auslocken.
Und nein,
er soll auch nicht
mein Mikrofon
crappen.
Weil wenn er mal ein Mikrofon crappt, dann hört er mich nicht mehr.
Sound machen wir aus.
Brauchen wir nicht, außer
doofes geklingeln unter Gnome bringt uns das ja eh nix.
So, wir haben schon fertig installiert.
So, machen wir das mal groß, dass man das
ordentlich sieht.
Wobei, bei der Installation wird man
denke ich eh nicht so viel sehen.
Es ist halt alles noch sehr beengt hier.
Okay, es ruckelt
schon mal.
Install.
Moin, ScaryLeggy.
Vier Terabyte SSD
RAID 10. Das witzige
daran ist wahrscheinlich, dass das RAID 10
langsamer ist als eine einzelne SSD.
Jetzt nicht sequenziell
oder so, aber zu Christein.
Ähm.
Tja, können wir nachher machen.
Continuum.
Bisschen größer könnten sie die Standard-
Auflösung auch machen.
Äh.
Install.
Ja, passt alles.
Lautstärke, okay.
Von
geklimper zu Voice.
Wir sind in Berlin, das ist auch richtig.
Tastatur
wollen wir German Layout.
Ich lasse zwar, ich installiere
alle meine Software mittlerweile auf Englisch.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ich stell immer auf
deutsche Tastatur Layout um.
Du hast
ein QuietComfort 35 an.
Das Ding habe ich mir auch gekauft, letztens.
Ist richtig gut.
Bestes Link, beste.
Test, Testviertel, Maschinen
darf das Ding auch heißen.
Ultrasicheres Passwort hier.
Ihr könnt es kaum erraten.
Oh, mein Battlefield 3 Server
Spam vom Bot sollte ich vielleicht mal
ausschalten.
Ext.
Gut.
Was wusstest du das, was ich über Lull geschrieben habe gerade?
Was hast du denn über Lull geschrieben? Zeig mal.
Ähm.
Das weiß ich, das habe ich doch sogar letztens
erzählt im Stream.
Das habe ich doch sogar letztens im Stream erzählt,
dass das Lull da, also, dass die das nachgemalt haben,
das Lull, weil der Fotograf gemeckert hat,
der ihn fotografiert hat, was
total beschränkt ist,
eigentlich, ne? Dass das überhaupt geht.
Aber ich meine Copyright Lull.
Das versteht
eh keiner.
Das heißt jetzt, wenn quasi irgendeiner
mich in Nahaufnahme fotografiert,
wo sonst nichts drauf ist, dann habe ich nicht
automatisch die Rechte, weil da
meine Fresse drauf ist. Ne.
Sondern der Typ, der das fotografiert hat.
Ja, Tools installieren wir gleich.
Ich darf das Fenster
gar nicht, gar nicht
mehr moven hier. Auch okay.
Dann move ich halt nicht das Fenster. Hier oben darf ich
aber noch klicken. Da machen wir
jetzt nichts. Ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal installieren.
Darf ich hier klicken?
Oh, jetzt können wir uns den tollen
Ubuntu Installer angucken.
Ob die Bilder hier überhaupt aktuell sind.
Sieht eher aus, als haben sie das vor
fünf Ubuntu Versionen mal
in Screenshot von genommen.
Jetzt, in dem Installer fehlt eigentlich
bloß noch Ubuntu 17.10
ist das beste Ubuntu, das es
je gab.
So wie das früher bei Windows-Versionen
immer gewesen ist.
War das gestern, wo ich das erzählt habe? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ja, ja, ja. Ne, vorgestern
war das.
Vorgestern war das.
Ich habe das jetzt übrigens mal in Kategorie
Creative Programming gemacht, weil das der Sache noch
am nächsten kommt.
Was anderes gibt es nicht
auf Twitch, was passt.
Ich bringe mal nebenbei meinem Bot bei,
dass der nicht mehr meinen
Battlefield-Server spammen soll,
während Ubuntu installiert.
Installation is complete.
Super.
End-Timer.
Kannst schon mal neu starten.
Jede Ubuntu-Version,
die ich bisher getestet habe,
jede Beta-Ubuntu-Version hat es übrigens
nicht geschafft,
lustigerweise nach der Beta schon,
aber die machen es in der Beta irgendwie immer kaputt,
also kann man es ordentlich neu starten,
nach Installation.
Sieht wieder so aus, als hängt es jetzt.
Weiß nicht,
was die haben immer.
So,
jetzt machen wir hier nochmal Server Disable,
dann spammt er nicht mal alle 10 Minuten
meinen Battlefield-Server.
Ja, das hängt wieder.
So geil.
So,
Connected Power On brauchen wir nicht.
Wir machen jetzt,
wir schalten es wieder aus und schalten es wieder an.
Hopp.
Zack. So, und jetzt gucken wir uns das neue
Ubuntu mal an.
Das nervt nicht, ich will das nicht ändern.
Und das will,
ich will auch nicht mein Mikrofon connecten.
Ah, das sieht so aus als,
wow.
Ah ja, okay.
Scheint was zu machen.
Wir müssen natürlich gleich noch Forever Tools installieren,
dass wir Fullscreen kriegen.
So, auf das Passwort kommt,
wow, was ist das für ein Input-Lag?
Alter, das ist ja nicht normal.
Hallo?
Komm, pass mal auf, ich drück jetzt mal.
Eins.
Was ist denn das?
Also, wenn das jetzt auch gleich so laggt,
wenn wir auf dem Desktop drin sind,
kann man das mal voll vergessen.
Zwei. Moment.
Moment.
Die Tastatureingaben sind an die Maus gekoppelt.
Guck mal, ich drück drei, es passiert nichts,
ich bewege die Maus, es ist sofort da.
Pff.
Ganz schön kaputt.
Okay, wir installieren jetzt hier gleich einen neuen Desktop.
Ja, da merkt man schon,
dass das noch ein bisschen Beta ist.
Tastatureingaben an Mausbewegung gekoppelt
ist vielleicht nicht die cleverste Idee.
Ansonsten läuft es doch
verhältnismäßig flüssig.
Oh.
Na ja.
Uh.
So, jetzt installieren wir erstmal Forever Tools,
dass wir
Fullscreen kriegen.
Ähm.
Open4M wäre...
Nee, Quatsch.
Open4M Tools.
Open?
Ach.
Wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt...
Oh, das...
Inputlag des Todes.
Und wenn ich die Maus bewege, dann kein Inputlag.
Na, ob das so gewollt ist?
Äh.
Install
Open4M
Tools.
Stop.
Wenn man die Maus bewegt,
ist der Input schnell.
Das ist schon Fail.
Machen wir das vorher noch?
Nee, wir installieren erstmal die Forever Tools.
Okay, das heißt,
ich muss die Maus bewegen, dass es repainted.
Geil. Perfekt.
Das...
Ich hoffe, das ist in der fertigen Version nicht so,
sonst werde ich das garantiert nicht verwenden.
So, ähm. Forever...
User...
So.
Und jetzt sollten wir Fullscreen kriegen. Jawoll.
Ha. Nice.
Ist es jetzt besser mit Tippen?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Das hakt ja.
Das ist hier neue User Experience.
Das stimmt. Man muss quasi mit einer Maus parallel...
äh, mit einer Hand die ganze Zeit die Maus bewegen,
dass man tippen darf.
Super.
Okay.
Dann darf der jetzt Updates machen.
Ich hoffe, das wird sich dann erledigen mit dem...
...
Vielleicht, wenn ich mal den Desktop hier umstelle.
Weil den, granum 3, will ich hier nicht verwenden.
Wir suchen uns jetzt schon mal raus,
das Repo ,
wo wir...wo wir Sway herkriegen.
Gab's irgendwo, habe ich gesehen.
Sonst...sonst...sonst hätte ich jetzt gar nicht auf die Idee,
wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen,
das jetzt auszuprobieren.
Wo war das denn?
Das ist alles ein bisschen hakelig, irgendwie...
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, das ist wie gesagt,
Beta und...
Ein Monat vor Release, ist, für Ubuntu, in der Regel ziemlich viel.
...
Die releasen zwar jedes...
Warte, der ist auch gar nicht fertig.
Ah!
Das sieht irgendwie alles noch ein bisschen kaputt aus.
Die releasen zwar jedes halbe Jahr, deswegen würde man denken, hey, die müssten auch fast fertig sein, quasi einen Monat vor Release.
Aber bei Ubuntu ist das so, die sind eigentlich bei Release noch nicht mal fertig, richtig.
Das heißt, einen Monat vor Release ist Ubuntu noch sehr, sehr roh.
Als nächstes.
Nein, das hier will ich nicht.
Also ich will es mir bestimmt nicht selbst kompilieren.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Bye.
Sieht jetzt nicht nach so einem Mega-Akt aus.
Ein paar Abhängigkeiten installieren.
Also, falls es nicht geht, können wir das im Zweifelsfall auch selbst kompilieren.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so kompliziert aus.
Das ist zwar der Debian-Installation-Guide, aber der wird für Ubuntu bestimmt auch funktionieren.
Wo gab es denn das Ubuntu-Repo?
Das da war das.
Yanox HDX.
Fragt, wie steigt man am besten in Linux ein?
Habt noch keine Erfahrung.
Ja, also das Beste ist, das mit Abstand, also meiner Ansicht nach mit Abstand Beste ist,
du installierst dir eine Virtualisierungslösung, also sowas hier wie VMware.
Und du siehst ja, ich habe hier Windows drumherum.
Und in der VM läuft jetzt das Linux.
Du installierst dir VMware Workstation, musst dir kaufen.
Du kannst dir auch VirtualBox installieren, das ist kostenlos.
Und auch VMware Player.
Und da kannst du ganz normal quasi in deinem Windows,
wenn du das so willst, einen virtuellen Rechner erstellen, indem du dann ein Linux installierst.
Das ist zum Ausprobieren das Beste, beste Variante, die es gibt.
Und als Einsteiger-Distribution würde ich sagen, oh, ich habe eine Donation gekriegt.
Da, fuck.
Musst gucken.
Der Domi hat donatet 1 Euro, danke.
Und fragt, benutzt du, Moment, ich beantworte erstmal das andere, fertig, sonst vergesse ich, sonst komme ich durcheinander.
Als Einsteiger-Distribution.
Als Einsteiger-Distribution würde ich entweder empfehlen Ubuntu, jetzt aber nicht unbedingt gerade die Beta-Version.
Wobei man sagen muss, Ubuntu ist als Einsteiger-Distribution gut, allerdings in der VM nicht so sehr.
Zumindest bis jetzt, weil die Standard-Ubuntu-Installation hat, wie gesagt, einen eigenen Desktop, der in der VM nicht so gut läuft.
Ubuntu ist eine super Einsteiger-Installation, aber für VMs eher nicht.
Kann man aber machen, funktioniert gut genug.
Ansonsten, was ich persönlich super finde, das ist aber ein bisschen was für Fortgeschrittene, ist Manjaro Linux.
Ist das System, was ich verwende.
Ich verwende normalerweise kein Ubuntu.
Was auch ganz gut ist zum Einstieg, ist ein aktuelles Fedora.
Ist auch ganz nice.
Da lernt man ein bisschen so die Red Hat-Seite kennen, das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Oder aber, man installiert sich ein Ubuntu.
Und scheißt auf den Unity-Desktop und installiert sich gleich einen anderen.
Dann funktioniert das nämlich auch super in der VM.
Aber in der VM testen ist das Beste.
Ich würde es nicht auf Hardware testen und schon gar nicht würde ich quasi meine, irgendwie Gefahr laufen, meinen Rechner damit kaputt zu machen.
Indem ich es irgendwie versuche parallel zu installieren oder sonst was.
Kann man den Scheiß nicht ausblenden da oben.
Das geht mir jetzt schon auf den Sack.
Ja.
Das würde ich empfehlen.
So und jetzt zur Frage.
Von einer Donation.
Benutzt du Linux bzw. Ubuntu als sekundäres Betriebssystem oder für was alles verwendest du es?
Also ich verwende Ubuntu auf der Arbeit hauptsächlich, also quasi nur.
Habe ich auf meinem Rechner dort installiert, also sprich direkt auf der Hardware.
Da ist es in dem Fall ist es Manjaro Linux.
Also ist ein Arch Linux drunter.
Zuhause habe ich auf meinem Desktop Windows.
Allein schon wegen den Spielen drauf.
Allerdings verwende ich auch eine VM mit Manjaro Linux für alles was, was Netzwerksachen geht.
Administrationsgedöns und eigentlich für alles, wo man nicht unbedingt Windows braucht.
Und Linux läuft auch wunderbar in einer VM.
Manjaro i3 WM drauf.
Super Umgebung auf meinem Server läuft in Ubuntu Server 16 16 17 04.
Ich hoffe das beantwortet die Frage.
Okay, zweimal hier mal weiter so viele Fragen kommen, kommen da gar nicht hinterher, was zu machen, wie hat man diesen Mist hier oben nochmal ausgeblendet?
Das ging konnte den Scheiß hier oben ausblenden, dass man es nicht mehr gesehen hat, wenn ich jetzt Exklusiv Mod anmache.
Wie mache ich den wieder aus?
Control Alt Key.
Ha, so ist das perfekt.
Jetzt kann ich hier kann ich auch nicht mehr aus Versehen rausklicken und sowas.
Ja, das ist gut.
Exklusiv Mod.
Ähm, The Blue Scream schreibt die VM würde ich allerdings nur empfehlen, wenn man einen potenten PC hat, sonst ist die Experience kacke.
Es geht eigentlich, also man muss schon, man muss schon einen richtig kack Desktop haben, dass man keine VMs heutzutage ausführen kann.
Jeder halbwegs aktuelle Prozessor und jeder, jeder halbwegs aktuelle RAM Bestückung reichen eigentlich aus, um wunderbar noch eine Linux VM laufen zu lassen.
Wenn man jetzt nicht gerade ein 10 Jahre altes System hat, ist es normalerweise überhaupt kein Problem eine VM laufen zu lassen.
Sei es jetzt mit mit Vmware Workstation, Vmware Player, VirtualBox, ist eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Und wenn das System so kacke ist, dass man keine VM drauf laufen lassen kann, wird das System, wird, wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht ordentlich laufen, wenn man es parallel installieren würde.
Wie kommt mir so voll, dass die Musik zu laut ist, aber ist sie gar nicht, ne?
Ist gerade harte Seitenarbeit angesagt.
Okay, wo ist denn jetzt das, das, das, das, ah hier, da ist es doch.
Installation Package.
Äh, Sway, genau.
Fügen wir mal Repos hinzu.
Oh!
Jetzt habe ich Musik Player gestartet, als wollte ich das jetzt.
Lull.
Exclusive Mode. Ja, nerv nicht.
Ich bin, ich bin so die, die i3 Abkürzungen gewöhnt.
Äh, Felix schreibt, die Musik ist gut.
Okay, also sagt einfach Bescheid, ob zu laut oder zu leise, wenn irgendwas ist.
Ähm, ich bin so die, die Shortcuts gewöhnt von i3, dass ich jetzt automatisch versuche mit Windows Taste 1, 2, 3, 4 die Desktop durchzuschalten, die es hier gar nicht gibt.
So, ähm, hat er jetzt eigentlich Updates installiert?
Er hat Updates installiert, okay, Restart, nein, ja.
Ja, komm.
Wir lassen ihn nochmal Restarten.
Bitte ohne Musik.
Ich finde das eigentlich echt entspannend im Hintergrund, so ein bisschen...
Bisschen Klaviergedudel.
Ähm, Marvin, ne, das mit Alienware ist noch nicht ordentlich spruchreif.
Jetzt haben sie aber auch komisch gemacht, dass hier das Login jetzt kommt und danach nochmal auf die Konsole geschaltet wird.
Hallo, wie wäre es mit, wie wäre es mit auf Fullscreen schalten, Ubuntu?
Wo ist jetzt...
Na ja, dann eben nicht.
So, jetzt installieren wir den i3.
Man sieht schon, es spackt ein bisschen rum hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Also, das ist noch ziemlich unfertig.
Habt ihr ja gerade gesehen, das Ding hat versucht auf Fullscreen zu gehen, hat gedacht, nee, ich bin gar nicht Fullscreen.
Das Fenster tut nur so.
Okay.
Und das Menü ruckelt auch.
Aber so ist das halt mit 3D-Beschleunigung, also mit, ähm, Grafikbeschleunigung in 4M, das funktioniert in der Regel nicht so gut.
So.
Dann fügen wir das mal hinzu, das Repo mit Sway drinnen.
Jawoll, ich vertraue dem Typ.
Ich kenne ihn zwar nicht, aber ich vertraue immer.
Übrigens, apt-get ist, ähm, nicht mehr so, wie man es macht unter Ubuntu.
Man verwendet jetzt nur noch apt.
Weil, warum auch immer, ist jetzt halt so.
Sprich, damit hat jetzt quasi Ubuntu oder Debian, ich gehe mal davon aus, bei Debian ist es auch so, damit hat jetzt Debian quasi 3-Wege-Pakete zu installieren.
Du hast apt-get.
Du hast apt.
Du hast aptitude.
Ach, das gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Ha.
Okay, das haben sie entfernt.
Dann ist es vielleicht doch irgendeine Ubuntu-Sache.
Ja, verifab, das stimmt.
Deswegen meinte ich vorhin, das Problem bei Ubuntu ist der Standard-Desktop, den sie da haben.
Der funktioniert in der 4M nicht gut.
Ansonsten ist 4M eine super, äh, ist, ähm, Ubuntu eine super Einsteiger-Distribution.
So.
Ähm.
Ja.
Jetzt installieren wir den Krampel mal.
Was, liest man bei Firefox unten die Meldung?
Das war wahrscheinlich vor dem Neustart, oder?
Ich habe das Comment zu spät gelesen.
Was, Debian hat noch alle 3?
Ja, ich verstehe nicht, was die, was die reitet, quasi 3, ähm, Frontends für ihr, oder zumindest Kommandozeilen-Frontends für ihr Paketverwaltung aus, äh, mitzuliefern.
Verstehe ich nicht.
1 und gut ist.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es installiert.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, jetzt muss ich nochmal, äh, Wayland neu starten.
Wobei, ist das überhaupt Wayland jetzt hier, oder ist das noch X?
Wie findet man das raus?
Check if Wayland running.
Wir können mal gucken, ob wir, ob man sowas hier gucken kann.
Ja.
Ja, sieht nach Wayland aus.
X-Wayland.
Warum haben sie es nicht einfach nur Wayland genannt?
How to know Wayland or X11 is being used.
Stack Overflow, beste.
Nein, Stack Exchange, ja.
Ist ja Admin.
Stack Overflow ist die Programmier-Seite, Stack Exchange ist die Admin-Seite.
Hat Login-CTL, habe ich noch nie ausgeführt, was ist das?
Da kennt man auch nichts wirklich drauf.
Was zum...
Was auch immer diese Befehle da jetzt...
Ah, Type Wayland, okay, alles gut.
Ähm...
Ah, ne, das, das sieht mir nach, das sieht mir nach der besseren Lösung aus hier.
Okay, es ist also Wayland, es ist nicht mehr X.
Also nicht mehr, nicht mehr, nicht mehr X11.
Beziehungsweise nicht mehr X.org.
Gut, dann gucken wir mal, ob der X-Server-Neustart-Shortcut noch funktioniert unter Wayland.
Nope.
Funktioniert nicht mehr.
Dann rebooten wir mal.
So wie man das von Windows kennt.
So, und ich hoffe jetzt mal...
XXWayland ist XX.
Genau.
XXWayland iScopes.
Rebooten wir mal.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass man in diesem Login-Manager auswählen kann...
Spray.
Also, dass man im Login-Manager Spray auswählen darf.
Also, ich weiß nicht, warum Ubuntu so auf diese komische...
Rauschen-Kotze-Farbgebung steht.
Das ist mir unbegreiflich.
Spray.
Sehr schön.
Da ist er.
Und er sieht aus wie i3.
Ich bin glücklich.
So, und wenn das jetzt noch ordentlich funktioniert...
Wuh!
Chrome-Terminal sieht schon mal ziemlich fail aus mit dieser extra Leiste hier oben.
Muss man gleich mal die...
Das Theme umstellen.
Chrome haben wir natürlich noch nicht drauf.
Wir machen uns jetzt mal ein ordentliches System, was man benutzen kann.
Da kann ich auch mal ein bisschen Spray ausprobieren.
Äh, hallo?
Hallo?
Ähm...
Das Ding hat ein bisschen Probleme mit Maus und Tastatur.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Menüs anklicken kann ich.
Allerdings...
Menüpunkte funktionieren nicht.
Aber mit Tastatur geht's.
Weil...
Warum auch immer.
So.
Das erste und wichtigste ist, man braucht ein ordentliches Farbschema.
Oh, ist das nervig.
Und hier dieses...
Mauszeiger.
Und dann das Carat für Text.
Das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt.
Das ist noch ein bisschen kaputt hier, würde ich sagen.
Kann man...
Was hat denn das Chrome-Terminal standardmäßig für Farbschema dabei?
Das backt alles übelst rum.
Die Maus backt total, ey.
Ich kann hier nichts auswählen.
Seht ihr das?
Oh, das ist ja fail.
Ich muss jetzt, dass das funktioniert...
Ich muss jetzt links klicken und mit der Tastatur hoch und runter drücken.
Und die Solaris halte ich nicht aus.
Äh, Solarise halte ich nicht aus.
Green und Black...
Ne, wisst ihr...
Wir installieren jetzt erstmal kurz den Chrome.
Wir installieren uns jetzt erstmal einen Chrome und dann installieren wir ein ordentliches Konsolen-Farbschema.
Weil ohne kann man nicht arbeiten.
Und dann müssen wir als nächstes noch eine ordentliche Schriftart installieren.
Und dann müssen wir das Chrome...
Chrome-Terminal...
Aber ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie ein...
Ein Wayland...
Äh, Gnome...
Sonst was backt, dass ich hier mit der Maus nichts...
Nicht richtig auswählen kann.
Und hier auch Mauszeiger und...
Und Text und so.
Dass das alles nicht so ganz stimmt.
Ihr seht's ja.
Guck mal.
Das ist irgendwie...
Irgendwie nicht so...
Nicht so...
Nicht so wie das...
Moment.
Jetzt geht das?
E...
Eben ging's.
Mit...
Mit Anklick...
Okay, das ist fail.
Okay.
Starten wir mal ein Chrome.
So.
Ähm...
Bestes Konsolen-Farbschema.
Der hier.
Also beziehungsweise ist es kein Konsolen-Farbschema.
Das ist...
Allgemein für...
Für alle möglichen Programme.
Gibt's das.
Was ist die Prick...
Please see, read me.
Das ist jetzt...
Wie entwickelt der Typ das nicht mehr weiter?
So.
Ey, ich hätte das gern für Gnome-Terminal.
Ach, hier.
Gibt's ja.
Genau.
Den will ich haben.
Und...
Für Shell.
Shell.
Klonen wir uns das mal.
So.
Wir müssen nämlich das Terminal jetzt erstmal dunkel machen.
Gibt ja Augenkrebs sonst.
Ist ein Git installiert?
Was?
Kein Git.
Bei der Gelegenheit können wir gleich mal Git installieren und wir installieren mal
Build-Tools.
Falls wir irgendwas noch selbst kompilieren müssen später.
Ähm...
Oh, ich hab jetzt einige Fragen, glaub ich, übersehen.
Äh, Chris Lee Wiesel fragt, kam das Git-Tutorial schon?
Nee, kam noch nicht.
Äh...
Nurlan Art fragt, welchen Texteditor nutzt du eigentlich im Terminal?
Wim.
Hauptsächlich Wim, wenn's...
Wenn's im Terminal sein muss.
So.
Kopieren.
Mäh.
Das Copy...
Sag mal, ist das Copy-Paste kaputt vielleicht?
Ich glaub das Copy-Paste ist kaputt.
Das ist natürlich doof, wenn Copy-Paste nicht funktioniert, ne?
Copy-Paste ist kaputt.
Das sagt.
Geht's denn umgedreht?
Copy...
Nee, Copy-Paste ist kaputt.
Liegt das am Chrome oder liegt das vielleicht am Browser?
Hm, Copy-Paste geht nicht.
Das ist ziemlich scheiße, dass Copy und Paste nicht geht, wisst ihr das?
Ich schieb das mal...
Ich schieb das mal auf Beta.
Das sagt.
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass Copy und Paste nicht funktioniert.
So.
Ich will das hier nicht clonen.
Also hier funktioniert Copy und Paste.
So.
Und hier?
Nicht.
Ganz toll.
Gut.
Dann scheißen wir mal auf Gnome-Terminal.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal den Klassiker.
Zumindest...
Oh.
Ich geh's zu arm.
Darf ich hier Copy-Paste?
Ja, hier funktioniert Copy und Paste.
Dafür sieht hier der Mauszeiger noch hässlicher aus drin.
Oh, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
X-Term halte ich nicht aus.
Was können wir ansonsten für ein Terminal installieren?
Wir könnten mal...
Wir probieren jetzt mal das KDE-Terminal aus.
Das werde ich aber nicht verwenden.
Ich will einfach nur mal wissen, ob es funktioniert.
Das scheint ja nämlich hier noch ein paar Probleme zu geben.
Oh.
So.
Wir installieren jetzt erstmal halb KDE mit, dass wir ein Terminal installiert bekommen.
Ist es normal, dass mein Game laggt, wenn ich nebenher Stream schaue?
Fragt IronHorse.
Das kann sein.
Je nachdem wie dein Rechner ausgelastet ist und ob Hardware-Decoder verwendet wird, CPU-Decoder
oder sonst was.
Nee, Terminator mag ich nicht.
Ja.
Mach ich.
Also es funktioniert beides nicht.
Bloß für mittlere Maustaste und...
Also hier ist Control-Shift-CV.
Funktioniert beides nicht.
Ah, hier geht's drinnen.
Hier geht's.
Und hier geht auch...
Hier...
Hier gehen auch die Menüs.
Haha.
Der Mauszeiger sieht zwar immer noch ziemlich fail und kaputt aus, aber ich meine, who cares,
ne?
Moment.
Jetzt gehen die Menüs wieder nicht.
Oh, ist...
Das ist ja mega kaputt, der Scheiß, ey.
Also das schiebe ich mal auf die noch ziemlich schlechte Wayland-Unterstützung.
Stimmt, die haben...
Haben die echt einen Donate-Button?
Donate.
Jawoll.
Beste.
Donate-Button in der Konsole.
Ja, warum nicht?
Also irgendwie, wenn man noch nicht mal eine Konsole ordentlich zum Laufen kriegt...
Wie sieht's denn mit...
LX Terminal aus?
Wir installieren jetzt mal ein paar Konsolenfenster und gucken mal, wie die ausschauen.
LX Terminal ist auch GTK-Anwendung.
Okay, hier funktioniert das Menü.
Funktioniert denn hier Copy und Paste?
Funktioniert hier Copy und...
Funktioniert auch Copy und Paste.
Also das Gnome Terminal scheint ziemliche Probleme zu haben.
Na?
Gnome Terminal funktioniert kein Copy und Paste.
Hat keinen Bock.
Will nicht.
Das Gnome Terminal ist generell ziemlich kaputt.
Aber hier?
Hier?
Oh, jetzt sind die Menüs wieder kaputt.
Oh, ist das Fail?
Egal.
Ähm...
Wir clonen jetzt erstmal das Repo und machen uns ein ordentliches Konsolenfarbschema.
Und vorher installieren wir eine ordentliche Schriftart.
Ähm...
Search.
So.
Hack wollen wir installieren.
Beste Schriftart.
Braucht man.
Hack.
Ne, Fonts Hack.
Das braucht man.
Die ist essentiell.
Ohne die geht das nicht.
So, und danach mach ich die Schrift...
Machen wir hier ein bisschen größer.
Also ich muss sagen, der Display Manager... äh, der Window Manager funktioniert astrein.
Die Programme funktionieren nicht so richtig.
Aber da kann ein Sway ja nix für.
Oh, das sieht auch schon mal elektronisch aus.
Das sieht ja hier aus wie 1995, so.
So, wir wollen Hack haben.
Hack.
Schriftgröße machen wir mal 16 oder so.
Ah.
Das ist doch gut.
So, und jetzt können wir das clonen.
Gucken ob das Farbschema funktioniert.
Queen of Black.
Ne, Queen of Black.
Gibt es da...
Queen of Black geht nicht.
Base 16 ist das beste Farbschema, finde ich.
Moment.
Wie führt man das jetzt aus?
Da fuck.
Z-Schellen müssen wir noch installieren.
Colortest.
Okay.
What?
Ah!
Base 16 tomorrow night wollen wir haben.
Permission denied, ja.
Source.
Ha!
So ist das schön.
So gefällt mir das.
Das ist das beste Farbschema.
Allerdings, der Hintergrund stimmt nicht.
Den Hintergrund müssen wir wahrscheinlich dann noch...
Also Konsolenfarbschema, das ist das...
Sonst kann man nicht arbeiten.
Das funktioniert nicht.
So, da müssen wir installen.
Das muss sein.
Was wir brauchen?
Einen Hintergrund.
Zeig mal Evoli, was ist das für ein Hintergrund?
Boah!
Da kriegst du ja auch einen Krebs bei.
So.
Das sieht doch schon ganz, ganz brauchbar aus.
Wie kann man, wie kann man LX-Terminal denn den Hintergrund verstellen?
Geht das überhaupt?
Wir gucken nochmal, wie es bei Gnome-Terminal aussieht.
Normalerweise höre ich Gnome-Terminal.
Allerdings spackt das hier gerade extrem rum.
Scripts.
Jaja.
Ha!
So gefällt mir das.
Wenn ich jetzt hier oben...
Wir müssen unbedingt gucken, wie man, wie man ordentliche Gnome-Themes einstellt.
Okay.
So gefällt mir das.
Also, Gnome-Terminal hat echt Probleme, ja.
Hack.
So ist das gut.
So muss das sein.
So muss eine Shell aussehen.
Wenn jetzt noch copy-paste funktionieren würde, lol 3d.
Das ist doch schön.
Jetzt haben wir eine Shell, die gut aussieht.
Problem ist, copy-paste geht nicht.
Ähm.
Oh, wie, wie, wie heißt dieses Gnome-Terminal?
Gnome-Terminal?
clipboard oder so dass die hatten doch so einen eigenen clipboard manager nicht install search
klipper gpast hieß es ich muss unbedingt meine alias wieder anlegen weil jetzt kann man so
machen bestes alias braucht man sonst muss man immer ganze zeit sudo tippen und übrigens soll
ich noch was cooles zeigen und richtig krassen hex hier mal angenommen ihr habt das hier jetzt
ausgeführt und sagt auch frag ich habe vergessen zu einzugeben dann gibt ihr ein sudo so und dann
macht das das führt den letzten befehl noch mal aus und jetzt die premium variante ja fest
ich habe vergessen zu einzugeben tag in your face würde aus richtig kasse hex oder gepaste gepaste
gepaste
gepaste sollte denn ich ja eigentlich hier oben normalerweise jetzt so eine
so eine menü area haben mein plan ja
es gibt sonst noch für für das kann aber die schilder
gibt es irgendwelche clipboard manager die funktionieren hallo
alles kann sein dass ich das konfigurieren muss dass er den kram hier oben anzeigt
gepasster das ist irgendwie alles ganz schöner fail oder das copy und paste nicht ordentlich
funktioniert wo sind wir denn im jahr 2017 weil die 15 jetzt super gepasste gestartet man das
denn gepasste die notification area hier macht man das ich brauche hier oben so eine anzeige für
für
photos
Ereignis. Wie macht man
das? Wie
zeigt man eine Tray Area an in
Sway? Das muss doch gehen.
Wenn es nicht geht, wäre ja
echt witzlos.
Wie macht man in Sway
Tray Area?
Where are my Tray Ereignis?
Sway Wiki. Gott.
Tray Ereignis. Wie jetzt?
Also ich will
Tray Ereignis haben. Da kann doch nicht sein, dass
das Ding keine Tray
Ereignis kann.
Der Domi. Hast du schon mal was von
Ubuntu Phones gehört? Ja, aber ich dachte, das ist
mittlerweile tot.
Okay, dann gucken wir, wir gucken jetzt mal
in die Config rein von
Sway.
Sway?
Ich glaube, wir müssen erstmal
einen Wim installieren.
Übrigens, ich will keinen Wim. Ich will
einen Wim
mit grafischer Oberfläche, allerdings
ich will die grafische Oberfläche nicht verwenden.
Ich weiß nur, wenn man einen Wim mit grafischer
Oberfläche installiert, dann ist auf jeden Fall alles
dabei.
Sway. Sway Config.
Sway Config.
Wie konfiguriert man Sway?
Configuration.
Ja, ich benutze die 3,
aber ich habe meine E3 Config hier nicht.
ETC Sway Config. Okay, die kann man
anscheinend anpassen. Oh nein, ich kann die nicht
copy-pasten. Habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Fail.
Und dann, wo soll ich die hinkopieren? Wahrscheinlich
nach .config Sway oder sowas.
Ich hoffe mal, das stimmt hier.
Ist jetzt einfach, ups, ist jetzt einfach,
geraten.
Ups, was mache ich denn hier?
So, config.
Ähm,
tray, ähm, bar.
Ah. Position,
bar, top, colors,
tray.
Tray output.
Tray output primary.
So.
Oh, ich kann ja nicht copy-pasten.
Ich krieg, ich krieg, ey, ich krieg.
Das geht nicht. Das halte ich nicht aus.
Das halte ich nicht aus,
wenn ich nicht copy-pasten kann.
Was? Tray output primary.
So, und jetzt das Ding reloaden.
Ist das hier gleiche Shotcut wie bei E3?
Ne?
Reload.
Mod, Shift, C. Was? Mod?
Mod, Mod, Shift,
Shift, C.
Habe ich jetzt Tray?
Habe ich jetzt ein Tray?
What the fuck?
Ich will doch einfach nur, dass copy-paste
funktioniert.
Also, das, sowas muss auch unter nem, nem
Beta-Ubuntu funktionieren.
Und ich will System-Trace haben.
Wir kriegen das schon hin.
Was gibt's noch für Clipboard-Manager?
Was, was gibt's denn da alles?
Wir probieren die jetzt alle durch, bis einer funktioniert.
Ja.
Arc-Wiki, äh, oder Arch-Wiki, beste.
Copy-Q.
Klingt gut.
Hat auch gute Bewertung. Das verwenden wir jetzt.
Copy-Q. Gibt's das jetzt?
Gibt's natürlich nicht.
Wenn ich das dann da richtig schreib.
Gibt's nicht.
So, was gibt's denn sonst noch für Clipboard-Manager?
Clip-It.
G-Paste.
Ja, G-Paste haben wir grad installiert.
Ge-, mit, mit, oh, ich kann nicht copy-pasten.
Benutzt du für Windows auch einen Clipboard-Manager?
Ne, unter Windows funktioniert sowas in der Regel.
Auch, ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass ich das jemals sah.
Ja, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber.
Unter Windows funktioniert die Zwischenablage.
Ah!
Ja, Roman.
Teste Ubuntu Beta und verzweifle an Zwischenablage.
Do you want to enable history?
Yes, natürlich.
Okay, jetzt, ich hab jetzt einen Clipboard-Manager laufen.
Fuck, Mann!
Das geht einfach nicht!
Das Clown Terminal verbuggt, hä.
Okay, und wir haben immer noch kein System-Trail.
Moment, verwendet das Ding hier überhaupt diese Config?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Wir machen die Config jetzt kaputt.
Und jetzt sollte er ja sagen, er kann nicht...
Okay, der nimmt die Config schon mal gar nicht.
Wo muss denn das Sway-Config hin?
Sway-Config.
Location.
Configuration.
Ja, hab ich doch gemacht.
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Da hab ich doch hin kopiert.
Ah, ComiBase geht nicht!
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Punkt.
Config.
Sway.
Genau da hab ich die hin kopiert.
So, und jetzt würde ich erwarten, dass der meckert,
wenn er das nicht laden kann.
Config. Sway-Config.
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Also, wenn's bei so einfachen
Dinger schon
hakt, ey.
Ich mein, ich mach jetzt die Config kaputt.
Ach, wir haben ja
noch nicht mal die richtige Shell hier laufen.
Ähm.
Ich starte den Krempel jetzt gleich nochmal neu.
Mod 4 ist Windows-Taste.
Alles gut.
Okay, also mit Windows-Taste schalten wir um.
Dann stellen wir das jetzt mal hier oben auf Alt.
Dann sollte es ja eigentlich nicht mehr gehen.
Der nimmt die Config nicht.
Okay, wir schreiben hier nochmal
irgendeine Scheiße rein und starten.
Äh.
Wie, wie kann man eigentlich...
Wie kann man eigentlich nur
Sway restarten? Geht das?
Ja, ihr verliert das Recht.
Ich mach jetzt einen Reboot.
Also, Copy und Paste hätte ich jetzt erwartet,
dass es mit
so verbreiteten, also dass es da
im Zusammenspiel keine Probleme gibt.
Weil ich mein, nen Chrome, beziehungsweise
Firefox als Browser und nen
Gnome-Terminal als Terminal,
das muss gehen. Und
Tray-Icons müssen auch funktionieren, sonst ist das
Ganze ja komplett unbrauchbar.
Und ich glaub, jetzt hängt's beim Reboot oder sowas.
Perfekt.
Beste.
Macht der noch was?
Scheiß drauf.
Bam.
Neustart.
Also, ich hab jetzt
irgendeinen Mist in die Config geschrieben, ne?
Ihr habt's ja gesehen.
Und vorhin hab ich gesagt,
do not show again.
Kann man mit Visual Studio Code sinnvoll C
programmieren, fragt xtheshadowghost.
Ähm, ja.
Kann man.
Kann man mit Visual Studio den passenden, also mit
Visual Studio Code und den passenden
Plugins fast alles machen.
Moment.
Jetzt geht noch nicht mal mein
Vollbild?
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Jetzt hab ich
echt gleich keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das Ding schaltet sich nicht
mal mehr auf Vollbild.
Lull.
Darf ich's von Hand umschalten?
Wie auch immer das ging.
Äh, äh.
Was weiß ich?
Wie ging das überhaupt?
Ne.
Was geht denn
bitteschön hier ab?
Oh, ich kann nicht mal tippen.
Das funktioniert noch nicht so richtig gut.
Sway Config.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich lösch die jetzt wieder.
Das Menü geht aber noch.
Config Sway.
Ich lösch die Config
jetzt wieder.
Ich lösch das ganze Verzeichnis.
Und jetzt reboot ich noch mal.
Okay, jetzt startet er sich schon mal neu.
Ob jetzt auch immer,
ob das jetzt ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Zeichen ist,
keine Ahnung.
Äh, ISO und wann das Programmieren weitergeht, spätestens
mit dem neuen Windows Update.
Was nächsten Monat kommt.
Also in 14 Tagen ungefähr.
Oder in 13.
Ähm.
Ah! Nice, funktioniert.
Das lag an der Config.
Moment, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Hier stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Okay, Tray Sachen funktionieren
schon mal gar nicht.
Äh, Gnome, wie hieß der Kram noch mal?
Gpaste.
Der funktioniert auch nicht.
Okay, dann starten wir jetzt noch mal
in Chrome.
Was wollte man eigentlich ursprünglich machen?
Oh, ich kriege echt die Krise.
Nein, Copy und Paste.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Dann verwenden wir jetzt ein anderes Terminal,
wo Copy und Pasten funktioniert.
Dann nehmen wir jetzt mal das,
was der Patrick eben vorgeschlagen hat.
Nehmen wir mal hin.
Nehmen wir mal einen Terminator.
Ja, ist der Bauer, das stimmt.
Hatte ich ja eben auch schon.
Das spackt auch so, ey.
Okay, anscheinend alles GTK-basierte
spackt.
Bei Copy-Pasten.
Ich starte jetzt noch mal Gnome
und gucke, ob das da auch so ist.
Woosa, moin.
Lässt du ja dein Linux, was im Alltag nutzt,
auch immer über eine VM laufen, oder?
Ne, also das Linux, was ich
auf der Arbeit verwende, nicht.
Ah, hier kann man umschalten, okay.
Das benutze ich auf der,
ist direkt auf der Hardware installiert.
Aber auf meinem Desktop
verwende ich das in der Regel in der VM.
Weil ich ja
das Windows zum Spielen brauche.
So, mal gucken, ob jetzt wenigstens
in Gnome selbst das Copy und Pasten ordentlich funktioniert.
Okay, hier funktioniert's.
Das wär jetzt
auch ein Witz gewesen, wenn's...
Ne, hier funktioniert's auch nicht.
Oder? Wart mal.
Doch, hier funktioniert's. Okay.
Also in Gnome selbst funktioniert der Kram.
Kann man, warum kann
man eigentlich nicht Lockout machen?
Das ist echt...
Ah, doch. Lockout.
Da liegt es irgendwie am Zusammenspiel
zwischen Gnome und Sway.
Das...
Irgendwie nicht.
Dann nehmen wir jetzt KDE Konsole.
Meinetwegen, kann ich auch mitleben.
Äh...
Gut. Okay, das macht einfach
nichts. Ist auch toll.
Pff, lol.
Außer irgendwelche komischen
Dinger ausgeben.
Also wir haben jetzt die Auswahl zwischen
Konsolen, wo Copy und Paste nicht
funktioniert.
Zwischen Sachen, wo das Farbschema nicht
richtig funktioniert. Ich glaub
LX Terminal war das einzige, was halbwegs...
gut funktioniert hat, oder?
Da hat aber der Hintergrund nicht funktioniert.
Ja, geil!
Wir haben kein Terminal, was ordentlich funktioniert.
Perfekt.
Das ist ja ne tolle Auswahl.
Dürfen wir
vielleicht jetzt ne...
Warte, dass ich hier so komische...
Hä?
Komische Zeilen oben dran hab.
Äh, Sway-Config-File.
Wir müssen uns da jetzt mal ein Config-File anlegen.
Okay, was nehmen wir jetzt?
LX Terminal nehmen wir jetzt.
Sieht zwar nicht schön aus,
aber funktioniert.
Config. Okay.
Achso.
Gut. Ähm...
So, dann passen wir die Config mal ein bisschen an.
Oh, sieht das hässlich aus.
Gibt es
nicht irgendein Terminal, was funktioniert?
Äh, X-Flame
hat's. Was ich heute mache? Ich will mir das neue Ubuntu
angucken mit dem neuen Display Manager.
Aber es scheitert schon daran, dass Copy und Paste
nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Und Menüs und sowas. Guck, du siehst,
die verschwinden immer zwischendurch.
Das ist alles noch ziemlich unfertig.
So, jetzt hab ich ein bisschen Farbe.
Passen wir die Config mal an.
Das brauchen wir eigentlich alles
nicht. Das können wir alles default
lassen. Gibt's
hier sowas wie Quit?
Sway, Quit.
Wie kommt man da wieder raus, ohne neu zu starten?
Was ist denn...
Ich verwende das normalerweise...
Ich quitte den ja normalerweise nicht.
Quit.
Mod Shift E.
Mod Shift E. Ha!
Funktioniert! Cool.
Immerhin.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr neu starten, um
die Config auszuprobieren.
Tray
Output
Primary. Hoffe, das funktioniert
jetzt so. E.
Haben wir jetzt einen
Tray? Immer noch
kein Tray. Das kann doch nicht sein!
Was ist das für ein Fail?
Ich will einfach eine Anzeige von
Icons im Tray haben.
Also, das scheitert ja gerade schon
an ganz grundlegenden Sachen,
dass das funktioniert.
Moment. Wie heißt mein Output?
Da wäre ich ja nie drauf
gekommen.
Mein Output heißt Virtual
Minus 1.
Das...
Kryptischer geht's
nimmer. Tray.
Heißt mein...
Heißt das Ding allen Ernstes
Virtual
Minus 1?
Kann doch gar nicht sein. Was ist das für ein beknackter
Name? Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man sich Tray
Icons anzeigen lassen kann.
Was gibt's in KDE Clipboard Manager?
Clipper.
Ist da irgendwas Neues?
Clipman. Diodon.
Ich installiere jetzt den ganzen
Kram, bis ich einen Clipboard Manager
hab, der funktioniert.
Aber ich weiß wenigstens, wie Copy-Paste funktioniert.
Wenn ich den Kram irgendwann mal verwenden muss.
Also, das Zeug startet und sollte
auch funktionieren, aber ich hab hier kein
kein Tray, was Icons
anzeigt. Das ist
echt Fail. Puh.
Okay, was unterstützen
die? Die unterstützen bloß Notification
Icons mit
Status Noti...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich hier mache.
Epic.
Wie ist da, wie ist das, den Clip, Clip...
Ne.
Copy-Q. Das Ding verwenden wir jetzt.
Ubuntu.
Jawoll.
Komm her.
Irgendein Clipboard Manager, der funktioniert.
Not found.
Und nun? Bleiben wir hängen, oder was?
Ah, der hat noch keine,
der hat noch keine...
Okay.
Der hat noch keine Pakete für das neue Ubuntu,
kann das sein? Oh, meine Güte.
Äh, kann man bei Ubuntu
KDE reinladen? Ja klar, kannst KDE
starten. Kannst KDE installieren,
kannst KDE starten, es funktioniert.
Wir kompilieren uns den jetzt.
Wir kompilieren uns das jetzt.
Wobei, das ist mir zu dumm für einen
Clipboard Manager. Alter.
Ich glaube ja, das Problem
liegt daran, dass meine
Config nicht richtig geladen wird.
Wir können es ja schon mal ausprobieren. Wir stellen
hier einfach mal...
Machen wir hier Position
Bottom, Bottom. Da würde ich
sagen, die Bar sollte unten sein.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Also im Prinzip, also die Config
wird geladen.
Output. Ja, also
dann probieren wir es nochmal anders.
Wobei, es ist natürlich bescheuert,
dass ich in Wayland mit X-Tools gucke.
Ähm...
Kann man Unity
für Artstellungs...
nutzen?
Theoretisch schon, aber ich weiß,
warum alles in der Welt will man...
Will man Unity verwenden?
Ich sehe nichts.
Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Es gibt keine Tray-Icons.
Was gibt es noch
für Programme mit Tray? Äh, äh, ähm...
Was ich machen will, ich will
mir einen Clipboard Manager installieren,
dass ich den Gnome Terminal ordentlich copy-pasten
kann, weil das ja anscheinend hier
noch verbuggt ist.
Mit einem ordentlichen Clipboard Manager funktioniert das bestimmt.
Allerdings,
Clipboard Manager kann ich mir nicht installieren,
weil ich keine Tray-Icons angezeigt kriege.
Da sehe ich nichts.
Das ist echt Fail.
Wie soll man das überhaupt verwenden ohne Tray-Icons?
Und wenn copy-paste nicht
richtig funktioniert und alles?
Hm...
Das wollen wir.
Welche Outputs muss ich denn da eingeben überhaupt?
Alter, Output...
Okay,
X-Runner soll nicht verwendet werden.
Okay...
Output virtual-1. Was soll ich jetzt
mit Output?
Okay, also der richtige Name wäre ja wahrscheinlich
virtual-1.
Aber wenn ich den hier eintrage für Tray-Icons,
dann...
klappt es nicht.
Ding startet, zeigt keine Tray-Icons an.
Wann ist das Fail?
Dann weiß ich auch nicht, was ich jetzt noch machen soll.
Dann würde ich sagen, der Test ist ganz schnell
in die Hose gegangen.
Hallo? Tray-Icons?
What the fuck?
Muss doch funktionieren.
Der startet das Ding, aber es
kommt halt nichts im Tray an.
Aber copy und pasten, na gut, das ist ja eh
LX-Terminal, da funktioniert es ja
eh.
Ich weiß nicht.
Und das Ding zeigt auch keine Fehler an.
Also,
irgendwie ist das noch sehr, sehr
hakelig alles.
Tray
Output Example.
Eine Sache probieren wir jetzt noch.
Ah!
Moment.
Habe ich überhaupt die richtige Version?
Habe ich überhaupt die richtige Version
von diesem Ding?
Aber...
Habe ich überhaupt die richtige Version?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Des allen Ernstes,
es gibt eine halbwegs aktuelle
Sway-Version, die keine Tray-Icons
unterstützt.
Was ist das denn?
Da habe ich ja gar keinen Bock weiterzumachen.
Lol.
Also ernsthaft jetzt.
Soll ich, soll ich mir wirklich
jetzt einen Sway 014 kompilieren, nur
dass ich Tray-Icons verwenden kann?
Und dass ich ein Display, dass ich
Clipboard-Manager starten kann,
dass ich im Gnome Terminal copy und pasten kann?
Es ist 2017!
What the fuck?
Das Ding zeigt ja auch
schon mal überhaupt keine Fehler an
oder so. Selbst wenn ich irgendeinen Scheiß
angebe, juckt es, juckt es einfach nicht.
Also, ich bin
nicht überzeugt, muss ich
jetzt mal sagen.
Nicht.
Echt mal ansatzweise.
Also, wenn das die Zukunft sein soll
von Linux Desktop,
dann sehe ich ja schwarz.
Ne, das Neue gibt es noch nicht im
Repo.
Im Repo gibt es nur, gibt es plus 13.
Moment, der Song
übersteuert.
Naja, gut. Was können wir sonst noch
ausprobieren? Wir können jetzt
mal, also wenn wir jetzt mal davon absehen, dass
Tray-Icons nicht ordentlich funktionieren.
Okay.
Und wir dementsprechend
keinen, also alle GTK
basierten Terminals funktionieren,
die Menüs nicht richtig.
Ähm.
Siehe, siehe hier, so Dinger, ne.
Bei Chrome Terminal funktioniert
hier schon mal gar nichts richtig und auch
kein Copy-Paste. Hier in LX Terminal
funktioniert wenigstens Copy und Paste.
Im Terminator funktioniert
nichts richtig.
Ähm.
Wir können auch mal
ein ordentliches Theme
für GTK Anwendungen
installieren.
Das ist dann immer ganz
so hässlich aussieht.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für
für Terminals? Jetzt mal von
von X Term und UXT
Dingsbums abgesehen.
Gibt es da irgendwelche neuen Sachen, die sich lohnen zu
zu verwenden? Wo vielleicht
alles funktioniert?
Konsole ist ganz okay, das funktioniert
noch am besten.
Kann aber ein paar Sachen nicht richtig haben will.
X Term, na, X Term ist
mir zu, zu oldschool.
Cool
Retro Term.
Wtf, warum hat das so viele
Bewertungen?
Okay, das ist eher ein Kunstprojekt
anstatt was, was man wirklich verwenden möchte.
Ja, LX Terminal
funktioniert
am besten.
Ich brauche einen ordentlichen Terminal Color, sonst
drehe ich durch.
Das könnten wir nochmal installieren. Das war ganz gut.
Das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Das war ganz gut. Mal gucken,
ob es das für Ubuntu gibt.
Gucken, ob es das für Ubuntu gibt.
Ja, zum selbst kompilieren.
Können wir aber machen.
Können wir machen.
Dann kompilieren wir uns das jetzt selbst.
Dann haben wir vielleicht ein Terminal,
was funktioniert.
Deluxe auf dem Desktop.
Wir können aber einfach das Skript
von dem Typ nehmen. Das sieht nämlich ziemlich
gut aus.
So als würde es einfach funktionieren.
So.
Vielleicht haben wir dann ein Terminal, was ordentlich funktioniert.
Das habe ich früher schon eine Weile verwendet.
Das war ganz okay.
Basiert auch auf dem ganzen Gnome Zeug,
aber ohne hier so viel Müll drumherum.
Aber ohne hier so viel Müll drumherum.
Am liebsten verwende ich ehrlich gesagt Gnome Terminal.
Deswegen ärgert es mich ein bisschen.
Das XFC Terminal können wir noch ausprobieren.
Deswegen
ärgert es mich ein bisschen,
dass es hier nicht richtig funktioniert.
Dann machen wir mal das Terminal.
Okay, der kompiliert jetzt das Terminal.
Alter, ich glaube es nicht. Wir kompilieren uns ein Terminal,
damit Copy & Paste funktioniert.
Wo sind wir denn?
Okay.
Das sieht nicht richtig aus.
Das Resize.
Das sieht nicht richtig aus, Leute.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
So sollte es bestimmt nicht aussehen.
Mit Ubuntu-Fenstern solltest du eigentlich auch nicht
haben, Terminal.
Irgendwie ist das alles
noch nicht so ganz fertig.
Klappt dann Copy & Paste?
Nein. Natürlich nicht.
Was eine kacke.
Copy & Paste funktioniert.
Nicht mal Copy & Paste.
Ja, was soll man da zu sagen.
Ja, Nulnart. Da mache ich auch gleich.
Also da ist mir dann auch
die Zeit für zu Schade.
Gucken wir mal, ob es hier funktioniert
mit Copy & Paste.
Oh, das hat auch Gnome.
Nope.
Funktioniert nicht.
Wie einfach nicht mal Copy-Paste geht.
Ich krieg echt die Krise.
Kann doch nicht sein.
So lächerlich.
Alter, das ist jetzt vielleicht generell ein Bug.
Was ich auch merkwürdig finde, ist hier das.
Ah, wobei, das Verschieben hier funktioniert halbwegs.
Also es scheint...
Es scheint kein generelles Problem zu geben.
Was hast du schon mal probiert, im gleichen Desktop Copy-Paste zu machen?
Ach so.
Ich kann das mal ausprobieren, aber ich hoffe mal nicht.
Nee, bringt nix.
Geht nicht.
Guck.
Ja.
Da.
Komm.
Copy.
Paste.
Geht nicht.
Also ich hoffe mal nicht, dass das die Zukunft ist.
LX Terminal funktioniert noch am besten, aber auch nicht schön.
Am besten hat...
Bisher eigentlich das ganze KDE-Zeug funktioniert.
Guck mal, wie lang...
Was ist das hier?
Nee, das ist alles noch ziemlich unfertig und kaputt.
Also wenn das in diesem Zustand rauskommt...
Moment, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt...
Eine Sache machen wir nochmal.
Die sind doch jetzt auch auf Wayland, oder Fedora?
Okay.
Wir installieren jetzt nochmal schnell Fedora.
Ich will einfach nur...
Gucken, ob das ein Problem ist von der Ubuntu-Beta, dass das alles nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Wollen wir das jetzt noch schnell ausprobieren?
Wollen wir noch ein Fedora installieren und gucken, ob diese ganzen Probleme an der Ubuntu-Beta liegen
oder ob das ein generelles Problem ist mit Sway und Wayland.
Ja, gut.
Dann laden wir uns jetzt nämlich noch ein Fedora runter, ein aktuelles.
Und dann schauen wir mal, ob das da auch so kaputt ist.
Ich hoffe ja nicht.
Weil...
Weil wenn das die Zukunft sein soll, dann hänge ich ja noch...
Hänge ich wahrscheinlich die nächsten fünf Jahre noch auf X.org rum.
Weil ich meine, dass Copy & Paste funktioniert.
Dass Tray-Eggs funktionieren.
Dass man gescheit Fenster resizen kann.
Und solche Sachen, das sollte Standard sein.
Das ist nichts mehr, wo man auch nur einen Gedanken dran verschwenden sollte 2017.
Das muss einfach funktionieren.
Also ich meine, dass ich die Programme installieren muss dafür.
Okay.
Aber danach sollte alles out of the box einfach tun.
Und für Copy & Paste muss ich auch nichts installieren.
Das muss einfach gehen.
Ne?
Also...
Das kann es nicht sein.
Äh...
Downloads.
Zwei Minuten, das geht schnell.
Äh, was hast du normal?
Das hier ist Windows 10, ja?
Das ist Windows 10.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, für...
Extra für Streaming-Zwecke einfach hier in der Default...
Mit den Default-Einstellungen und alles.
Ich habe einen extra Account gemacht zum Streamen.
Dass ich nicht noch aus Versehen meine Porn-Sammlung zeige oder so.
So.
Ubuntu machen wir platt.
Und danach, wenn das mit Fedora...
Also je nachdem.
Eigentlich ist es egal, ob es funktioniert oder nicht.
Das war ja nur zum Testen.
Und dann machen wir die VM wieder platt.
Das heißt jetzt halt nur noch Ubuntu.
Ist halt einfach wurscht, wie die VM heißt.
Nullen hat...
Ja, ja, ich habe auf meinem Server laufen...
Es läuft fast alles als VM.
Als VM oder als LXC-Container.
Auf, lad, runter.
Okay.
Ähm...
Ups, vielleicht sollte ich nochmal einstellen, dass da auch das Laufwerk startet.
Heftig.
Ich habe gesagt, neu starten.
Äh, start.
Start ist gut.
Wir starten.
Vielleicht hat Fedora auch mal, so wie das Manjaro beispielsweise hat,
standardmäßig die VMware-Tools dabei.
Ich finde es so nervig, dass man auf den meisten Distributionen
VMware-Tools nachinstallieren muss.
Warum werden die nicht einfach mitgeliefert?
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
vor allem im Desktop-Bereich,
also sprich alle Distributionen,
die sich irgendwie auch so ein bisschen am Desktop-Bereich richten,
weil sie halt mit grafischer Oberfläche daherkommen,
standardmäßig,
ein ganz großer Teil davon läuft eben in der VM.
Deswegen, warum nicht einfach
VMware-Tools standardmäßig installieren?
Ha!
Fedora hat VMware-Tools standardmäßig installiert.
Das ist mir doch recht sympathisch.
Und das läuft auch relativ schnell, muss ich sagen.
Und es ist auch Wayland.
Okay, also prinzipiell scheint das tatsächlich dann
eher an Ubuntu zu liegen.
Okay, wir installieren uns Fedora.
Äh, die Musik im Hintergrund ist, äh,
kann ich dir schicken.
Ist das hier.
The very best ist das.
The very best.
Das ist einfach ein Video, was
zwei Stunden geht.
Moment, was?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Man kann,
man kann,
man kann Fedora in irgendeinem deutschen Dialekt installieren.
Ist das denn hier ernst, ja?
Gut.
Meinenwegen, ja.
Ich würde gern hier noch
Tastatur umstellen.
Aber darf ich anscheinend nicht.
Ah, jetzt hat er es eingestellt.
Ähm.
Ja, die Fedora-Installation war schon immer merkwürdig.
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen,
hau alles weg?
Warte.
Ja, löscht den Scheiß einfach.
Brauchst du eh nicht mehr.
Alles löschen.
Was?
Okay.
Installation starten.
Root-Passwort.
Nein, ich will eigentlich kein Root-Passwort.
Ich will Sudon.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Vergebe ich halt ein Root-Passwort.
So ein wahnsinnig secure, highly secure.
Benutzer.
Test.
Admin.
Auch wieder High-Secure-Passwort.
So ein wahnsinnig secure.
Highly secure.
Benutzer.
Test.
Admin.
Auch wieder High-Secure-Passwort.
So ein wahnsinnig secure, highly secure.
Benutzer.
Test.
Admin.
Auch wieder High-Secure-Passwort.
So ein wahnsinnig secure.
Benutzer.
Test.
Admin.
Auch wieder Fine-Screen.
Gut.
Einfach mal vorbeif rejoinen.
Hher zumINGe.
Ja.
Jetzt aber noch ein Mal Nachrichtenressen.
Dann Protest.
Ja.
Okay.
So an.
Na sieht ja einfach alles跟nät.
Ja.
Geht noch mal nicht stool rum.
Guck mal, die...
Guck mal, die faken doch nicht mal den Fortschrittsbalken.
Die zeigen ihn einfach standardmäßig als voll an.
So kann man das auch machen.
Möchten sie Fedora besser machen?
Wir können ihnen helfen...
Ne.
Wir können ihnen helfen, uns zu helfen.
Ach sur.
Achtung.
Donate-Button. Aber ich muss
sagen, wenn ich überlege, was das
früher schon für ein
Akt teilweise war
und die Installer manchmal abgekackt sind
zwischendurch, wenigstens das funktioniert
mittlerweile gut.
Guck mal, also die Fedora-Installation,
das war jetzt ja fast idiotensicher. Da kann man
eigentlich nichts falsch machen.
Und was hat Hotdog mit Fedora
zu tun? Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Den hätten sie wenigstens noch einen Hut
aufsetzen können, oder?
Arbeit zu erledigen, installieren sie LibreOffice,
um Texte und Tabellen zu erstellen.
Und noch viel mehr.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass LibreOffice
sogar standardmäßig dabei ist.
Aber wenn sie es irgendwie
vermeiden lässt, verwende ich diese ganzen
Office-Geschichten nicht.
Ich glaube, kein Mensch
braucht wirklich eine Textverarbeitung.
Keiner braucht eine Textverarbeitung.
Ich habe noch keinen Anwendungszweck erlebt,
wo ich gesagt hätte, jawohl,
ich brauche jetzt eine Textverarbeitung.
Weil es ist einfach so,
wenn man Text schreiben will,
kann man das in einem Texteditor machen.
Und da gibt es auch so etwas
wie Rechtschreibkontrolle und so etwas.
Wenn ich was
schön formatieren will,
dann gibt es auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Die einfachste Variante ist,
wenn ich das mit Markdown zum Beispiel mache.
Gut, damit kann man jetzt nicht
gar so komplizierte Sachen machen.
Wenn ich es ein bisschen fancier machen will,
dann mache ich es mit Tech.
Oder im Zweifelsfall,
wenn es für irgendwelche Layout-Sachen ist,
dann mache ich es mit einem Layout-Programm.
Also eigentlich braucht man keine Textverarbeitung.
Also ich glaube, ich hatte jetzt,
ohne Witz,
ich hatte zum letzten Mal Word auf
vor sechs Jahren oder so.
Ich habe es, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr installiert.
Habe ich es überhaupt installiert?
Nö.
Habe ich LibreOffice?
Ja, das habe ich installiert.
Verwende ich nicht.
Auch Tabellen kann man...
Ich verwende...
Ich verwende eigentlich keine Office-Programme mehr.
Weil ich weiß gar nicht, wofür.
Vollständig.
Nach einem Neustart können sie beginnen.
Yeah.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, mit Markdown kommt theoretisch jeder klar.
Das gibt drei, vier Sachen,
die man sich merken muss.
Das war es.
Aber gut, für irgendwelche fancy Sachen
ist Markdown jetzt auch nichts.
Also muss dann wirklich auch
ein ordentliches Layout haben muss.
Ja, dafür...
Aber das wollen die meisten Leute noch nicht mal.
Hallo, ich wollte neu starten.
Oh, guck mal, das startet sogar automatisch.
Das funktioniert einfach.
Selbst für PowerPoint-Präsentationen.
Selbst dafür.
Kann man sich drüber streiten.
Es gibt richtig viele coole
browserbasierte Präsentationstools mittlerweile.
Es gibt auch Präsentationstools,
wo man Präsentationen komplett in Markdown erstellen kann.
Ich finde das alles irgendwie einfacher und schöner
als mit PowerPoint oder so rum.
Um so etwas zu wurschteln.
Oh, guck mal.
Hier ist übrigens die Tastatureingabe
und das Neuzeichen des Fensters
nicht an Tastatureingaben gebunden.
Unglaublich.
Es funktioniert.
Aber schwarz fällt es trotzdem danach.
Warum auch immer.
Aber das läuft schon mal eine ganze Ecke.
Okay, Einrichtungsassistent.
Okay, machen wir es halt in Deutsch.
Nee.
Wir machen die Sprache in Englisch.
Gut, das geht ja wenigstens.
Und Text.
Location Services.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
Next.
Nein, ich will mich nicht verbinden.
Start using.
Jawohl.
Verpiss dich.
Also das läuft schon viel besser als das Ubuntu.
Als das Beta-Ubuntu.
Muss man auch so sagen.
Das war ja Beta.
Okay, und jetzt installieren wir mal Sway.
Ähm.
Äh, DFM.
Oh nee.
Off.
Fuck.
Wie hieß der neue Red Hat Paketmanager?
D.
DF.
Oh, fuck.
Yam war gestern.
Yam verwendet man ja nicht mehr.
Ähm.
DNF hieß es.
DNF, genau.
Install Sway.
Alle wollen so, dass man irgendwo Accounts macht.
Ich will keine Accounts machen.
Ich will den gerade einfach verwenden.
Nice.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Es ist zwar lahm.
Aber.
RPM-basierte Distributionen sind immer schnarchlangsam bei Updates und bei Paketquellen aktualisieren
und alles.
Das zeichnet so dieses ganze RPM-Zeug aus.
Das ist einfach so krass langsam.
Nicht, dass Debian-Pakete so viel besser werden.
Am besten gefällt mir das Paketsystem von Arch Linux.
Alles ziemlich leichtgewichtig.
Äh.
Guck mal, die haben sogar das neueste Sway.
Da kann man sogar Tray-Icons wahrscheinlich verwenden jetzt.
Das stimmt schon.
Das aktuelle PowerPoint ist nicht schlecht im Vergleich zu den alten PowerPoints.
Okay, war es das jetzt schon?
Das ist ja easy gewesen.
Aber es steht natürlich Sway nicht da drin.
Wir starten mal neu.
Sicher ist sicher.
Man weiß ja nie.
Was ist denn für Dora?
Das ist eine Distribution von Red Hat.
Quasi die.
Bastel-Baustelle für Red Hat.
Sway.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Chrome.
Sind wir dabei?
Mal in Firefox mal starten.
Ah.
Gnome Terminal starten.
Oh, der hat meine Tastatur-Settings schon mal nicht mitgenommen.
Okay, mal gucken, ob Copy-Paste geht.
Ah, guckt hier mal.
Oh, ist das kaputt?
Dann ist das irgendein Sway-Bug.
Kann das sein?
Wenn hier noch nicht mal...
Wenn auch selbst unter einem aktuellen Fedora die...
Aber Copy-and-Paste funktioniert.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Copy-and-Paste geht.
Aber Desktop-Switchen geht hier nicht.
Das ist alles ziemlich kaputt.
Guckt, wenn ich hier in der Menüleiste bin vom Firefox, geht das Switchen nicht und sowas.
Das ist alles noch nicht so rund, muss ich sagen.
Das...
Also...
Wenn das Xorg ablösen soll und die Hälften nicht richtig...
Funktioniert, dann sehe ich da schwarz.
Ah, zumindest Copy-Paste funktioniert hier schon mal.
Aber guck mal, ich kann jetzt nicht den Desktop switchen.
Einfach, weil ich hier in irgendeinem Dialog drinne bin.
Das ist schon Fail.
Guck dir das mal an.
Hier, Menüs funktionieren hier auch nicht richtig.
Also, schön ist das nicht.
Äh, Sway of Arch habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Naja.
Ich habe auch auf meinem Anjaro normalerweise noch ganz normalen X drauf.
Tja.
Also, wenn das quasi unterm aktuellen Fedora nicht funktioniert, die seit einer Weile schon Wayland haben.
Und das insgesamt eigentlich somit am besten funktionieren sollte.
Guck, aber es ist hier auf jeden Fall viel besser.
Der Mauszeiger spackt nicht so rum.
Das, das, das ist schon fast benutzbar.
Fast.
Die Menüs gehen auch nicht mehr weg.
Aber halt, meine Maus erkennt da noch nicht.
Was ziemlich nervig ist.
Jetzt erkennt er sie.
Wenn man einmal da drin ist.
Jetzt erkennt er sie wieder nicht.
Und das sieht auch auf jeden Fall nicht richtig skaliert aus.
So ganz richtig funktioniert das noch nicht.
Und das Skalieren sieht ja auch mal ultra hässlich aus, ey.
Warum skaliert er das überhaupt so komisch?
Hallo?
Warum?
Ist das?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Warum skaliert er das bitte schon so?
Der soll, der soll, der soll die...
Ui-Elemente skalieren und nicht einfach das Fenster nur.
Sag mal, sind wir im Jahr 2000...
2001 irgendwie hängen geblieben, was Ui-Design angeht, Linux?
Oder was ist hier los?
Ne, siehbar.
Auch VMware-Tools sind installiert gewesen.
Gut, also unter Fedora funktioniert es auch nicht richtig.
Was mich zum Fazit bringt...
Für Xorg und i3-WM in Kombination gibt es noch keinen ordentlichen Ersatz.
Das heißt, ich werde auch, wenn das neue Ubi...
Ubuntu kommt, weiter auf Xorg bleiben.
Vielleicht tut ja Sway irgendwann mal.
Oder ich steig auf Mac um.
Lol.
Das ist schon enttäuschend, ne?
Geht...
Oh ja, eine Sache probieren wir noch.
Gehen dann jetzt hier Tray-Icons?
Gehen da Tray-Icons?
Ups.
Sway.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal.
Wir probieren mal Tray-Icons aus.
Ähm.
Sway.
Konfig.
Bro.
Ah, muss ich sagen, das haben sie ganz praktisch gemacht hier.
Wenn ein Kommando nicht gefunden ist, bietet er mir gleich an, das zu installieren.
Kann ich mitleben.
Finde ich praktisch.
Aber geil, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
DNF install.
What?
Ist...
Hat den Scheiß mal irgendjemand überhaupt getestet, bevor sie das releasen?
Ich werde doch hier keine Paketabhängigkeiten von Hand...
Irgendwie lösen.
Wo sind wir denn?
Hä?
Alter.
Wisst ihr was?
Ah, Nano-Signal installiert.
Ich verwende nie Nano normalerweise.
Aber wenn ich kein Wim installieren darf, aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Das ist schon bitter, ey.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich Arch-Linux verwende.
Da muss ich den Scrum zwar selbst einrichten, aber es funktioniert.
Wie sucht man überhaupt...
Wie sucht man überhaupt in Wim...
Äh, sorry.
Wie sucht man überhaupt in Nano?
Gibt's denn da...
Okay.
Okay, wie ging das jetzt mit...
Mit...
Mit Tray-Icon?
Tray...
Ne, wie war das?
Output...
Pr...
Prima...
Rina?
So, gucken wir mal, ob Tray-Icons hier funktionieren.
Nö.
Keine Tray-Icons.
Ah, Menüs, die funktionieren.
Immerhin.
Wann mal wieder ein Video kommt.
Wenn ich Bock hab, auf YouTube mal wieder was zu machen.
Das probier ich jetzt noch aus.
Output...
Copy & Paste geht jetzt, ja?
Oder auch nicht?
Ups.
Oh, ich werd tippt.
Geht's doch nicht.
Keine Tray-Icons.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Wieso?
Oh, wie hieß denn das ganze Kram?
Clip-It hieß das.
Clip-It gibt's auf jeden Fall.
Keine Tray-Icons.
Gut.
GG.
Also, ich bin nicht überzeugt.
Äh, was, Sibaro?
Meinst du, ich hab's an der falschen Stelle hingeschrieben?
Nee, oder?
Glaub ich nicht.
Das guck ich jetzt noch mal nach.
Ansonsten war der Test jetzt von neuer Linux-Desktop-Technologie nicht sonderlich erfolgreich.
Also, ich mein, dass so Sachen wie Copy & Paste nicht richtig funktionieren, Menüs nicht richtig
funktionieren und so, das ist schon hart lächerlich.
Moment.
Ich will keinen Xterm starten.
Aha.
So, du meinst, ich hab's an der falschen Stelle gemacht?
Ah!
Ich hab's an der falschen Stelle gemacht.
Stimmt.
Aber immer noch keine Tray-Icons.
Lol.
Keine Tray-Icons.
Jetzt guck ich noch mal, ob das auch richtig war.
Aber es war ziemlich sicher, war das Tray-Output.
Nehmen wir's noch mal so.
Guck mal.
Sogar mein Start-Menü ist gerade abgeschnürt.
Seht ihr's hier oben?
Das ist Fail.
Das ist echt...
Das kann man doch nicht...
Was zum...
Nee.
Keine Menüs.
Das ist wirklich nicht die Zukunft hier.
Das ist nicht die Zukunft.
Das ist auch so geil bei VM-Ware, ne?
Man kann die VM löschen, aber es ist im Endeffekt noch alles da.
Man muss danach in den Ordner gehen und noch mal löschen.
Weil weiß nur VM-Ware warum.
Gut.
Dann war das jetzt ziemlich für den Arsch.
Und ich weiß aber, zumindest eine Sache habe ich daraus jetzt gelernt.
Wenn das neue Ubuntu kommt, werde ich es noch mal wieder ausprobieren.
Ich habe es noch mal ausprobiert.
Und ich garantiere nicht auf Wayland umsteigen und auch nicht auf Sway.
Sondern ich werde bei X bleiben mit I3 und gut S.
Das funktioniert einfach.
Das funktioniert dann auch Copy Paste und RayIcons und ich kann Fenster richtig verschieben.
Also, ne?
Prozentual vom Bildschirm und sowas.
Funktioniert einfach.
Nee, nee.
Das hat mich echt nicht überzeugt.
Moin X-Cornier.
Ja.
So, jetzt bin ich fertig. Jetzt habe ich ausprobiert. Wie lange habe ich jetzt gestreamt? Inception. 2 Stunden 6. Ja, Flixcode, das gibt es. Wayland als neuen Display-Server. Aber wie man gesehen hat, jetzt funktioniert das Ganze noch mehr schlecht als recht.
Also, wenn das weiterhin so ist, würde ich sagen, auf absehbare Zeit wird da nichts Xorg ersetzen, wenn man noch nicht mal Fenster richtig resizen kann. Hallo? Das war so viel Fail in jetzt einer Sitzung hier, das kann ich ja, das weiß ich gar nicht, wie ich das noch irgendwie schönreden soll.
Copy-Paste geht nicht, Fenster lassen sich nicht resizen, Menüs sind auf einmal weg, Fenster verschieben.
Fenster verschieben lassen sich nicht ordentlich.
Sway funktioniert nicht richtig.
Also, ich sehe mich da in nächster Zeit nicht von Xorg und i3 woanders hin wechseln.
Gut, war eine spontane Sache mit dem Stream heute.
Äh, was?
Ah, Kenos, wieso hast du Destiny 2? Das kommt doch erst im Oktober für den PC.
Ja.
Das ist die Beta.
Das ist noch die Beta, die könnte ich jetzt eigentlich mal deinstallieren.
Removes.
Deinstallieren wir das doch.
Warum sehen die neuen Windows-UIs eigentlich so hässlich aus?
Aber das wird mit dem Update im Oktober besser.
Ich freue mich auf das neue Windows-Update. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Alle Leute sind ja so bei Windows-Updates in letzter Zeit so, oh, scheiße, dann geht es wieder nicht und updatet wieder eine Stunde und irgendwas geht eh in die Hose.
Ich freue mich auf das neue Windows-Update.
Weil zum ersten Mal es eine ordentliche, moderne Design, Designs gibt, eine Design-Richtlinie, wie Windows-Apps aussehen sollen und quasi die, die kompletten Apps, die dabei sind bei Windows halt auch so angepasst werden.
Du hast dann nicht mehr quasi Windows-Programme über drei Generationen, die alle unterschiedlich aussehen, mal eins mit Ribbon-Bars, einmal mit Tag-Context-Menüs, einmal mit so, einmal mit transparentem Hintergrund, einmal mit so.
Sondern die werden alle angepasst und es gibt dann auch eine ordentliche Richtlinie, wie Windows-Programme aussehen sollen.
Ich kann euch das mal zeigen, wie Microsoft sich das vorstellt.
Wobei das, glaube ich, so eine typische Marketing-Seite ist, wo man nicht viel daran erkennt.
Das ist wieder so eine absolut nichtssagende Seite, ja.
Da macht Microsoft mal was Gutes, ja.
Und die sehen auch wirklich gut aus, die neuen Anwendungen.
Und dann hast du hier so eine absolut nichtssagende...
Wer interessiert sich?
Für VR-Anwendungen, das juckt doch keinen.
Ja, hier erkennt man es so halbwegs.
Na, das auch nicht.
Hier erkennt man es ganz gut.
Da haben die irgendwie ordentliche Beispiele.
Das ist auch so typisch Microsoft, ne?
In der heutigen Zeit, da muss man einfach korrekt sein.
Wenn man Werbung macht, dann braucht man einen Asiaten, dann braucht man einen Schwarzen, dann braucht man hier natürlich hier blond, blond und weiß.
Und, na, jetzt fehlt bloß eigentlich noch ein Mexikaner oder so.
Das machen die gerne bei Microsoft.
Das muss dann immer so schön...
...repräsentativ für alle sein.
Und der größte Fail war, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das kennt, ähm, da haben sie ein Bild angepasst.
Das war, da hatten sie ein Bild mit...
Oh, ich muss euch das mal zeigen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das seht.
Microsoft-Marketing-Fail.
Was ist der politisch korrekte Ausdruck jetzt für schwarz?
Darf man das sagen?
Ja!
Das da!
Und...
Oh, gibt's das?
Gibt's das in groß, das Bild?
Ja, genau, ich weiß nicht.
Ich, ich zoome mal.
Erfällt euch was auf an dem Bild.
Fällt euch daran was auf.
Mein, außer, dass es das gleiche Bild ist und dass hier der, dass hier der Typ anders aussieht.
Aber fällt euch noch was auf.
Das meine ich nicht.
Also, dass der Typ hier ein anderer ist, klar, aber fällt euch an dem Typ was auf.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut man das im Stream erkennt.
Ich zoome mal ran.
Passt mal auf.
Guckt euch mal die Hand von dem Typ an.
Fällt euch da was auf?
Die haben die Hand nicht ausgetauscht.
Guckt mal.
Man sieht ja auch, dass es überhaupt nicht passt.
Marketing-Fail.
Äh.
Ich finde, ich finde das an sich, kann ich das verstehen, ja.
Dass man, dass man die Leute hier drauf anpasst.
Aber dass man halt hier nicht aufpasst.
Mit der Hand.
Das finde ich halt Fail.
So.
Aber um jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen Sache zurückzukommen.
Ähm.
Wir gucken uns da mal ein paar Bilder zu an.
Irgendjemand hat gerade im Chat geschrieben, ist auch dringend nötig mit der, mit der einheitlichen Design-Richtlinie.
Ähm.
Ist es auch.
Es gibt ein Video.
Gucken wir mal, ob man hier was Gescheites drin sieht.
Ja, hier erkennt man es ein bisschen.
Na, hier erkennt man es ein bisschen.
Das, das, das ist nicht wirklich, das ist keine richtige Transparenz zum Beispiel.
Also sprich, das ist nicht so, so einfach Hintergrund genommen und geblurrt.
Sondern es sorgt tatsächlich dafür, dass man immer noch guten Kontrast zum Vordergrund hat.
Aber es trotzdem so aussieht, als würde der Hintergrund durchschimmern und sowas.
Das ist richtig cool, was die sich da ausgedacht haben.
Ähm.
Kann ich noch was zeigen?
Das kommt halt mit dem neuen Windows-Update.
Deswegen freue ich mich da drauf.
Das wird auch mal Zeit.
Weil ich meine, das kann doch nicht sein, dass du auf dem aktuellen Windows parallel sowas hier hast.
Na.
Also, mir ist klar, dass das eine Paint ist und das andere der, der Calculator.
Äh.
Und danach hast du noch sowas.
So.
Das sind quasi die Anwendungen-Designs aus jeweils einem eigenen Jahrzehnt.
Das ist 1990.
Das ist 2000.
Das ist 2010.
Also, du hast quasi Standard-Anwendungen, die parallel bei Windows drin sind.
Und alle drei, behaupte ich mal, sogar relativ beliebte Anwendungen sind.
Ähm.
Hast du ein Design 1990, 2000, 2010.
Und das darf es halt nicht sein.
Guck, man sieht hier auch schon, dass hier schimmert hinten einfach nur ganz normal Blur durch.
Genau.
Und dann siehst du das nächste, weil es gerade einer geschrieben hat, System-Besteuerung.
Das nächste Dilemma war es Microsoft.
Da siehst du mal das System.
System-Besteuerung.
Ähm.
Eigentlich wollten wir Destiny deinstallieren, ne?
Fällt mir nur gerade so ein.
Wir machen das gerade mal.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ja.
Jetzt ist Destiny weg.
Also das erste, das Dilemma, was Microsoft, da sieht man auch an der System-Besteuerung.
Das ist, das ist quasi die neue System-Besteuerung.
Und dann hat man immer noch, da hat man immer noch die hier.
Die alte.
Von 2000 rum, so.
Sagen wir mal 2005 oder sowas.
Gut.
Ähm.
Man sieht auch hier wieder, dass die System-Besteuerung, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben, die wir jetzt haben.
Die System-Besteuerung ist wieder komplett andere Bedienung, komplett anders aufgebaut.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wo findet man was?
Findet man es da drin?
Warum kann ich Programme hier deinstallieren und hier deinstallieren?
Warum?
Wo, wo ist der Sinn?
Hä?
Hier kann ich die Windows Firewall ausschalten.
Und hier kann ich die Windows Firewall ausschalten.
Aber manche Sachen kann ich hier drin machen, aber nicht hier drin und manche hier drin und manche nicht hier drin.
Dann fragt man sich, wie kann ich die Windows Firewall ausschalten?
Dann fragt man sich, was, was geht in den Jungs vor, ne?
Aber ich finde, das hier ist so das beste Beispiel für Wildwuchs unter Windows und einfach, einfach Fail der letzten 20 Jahre.
Sowas hätte es bei Apple nicht gegeben, auch wenn ich kein Apple-Fan bin.
Es kann nicht sein, dass du quasi drei beliebte Standard-Anwendungen hast und alle drei mit komplett anderem Bedienkonzept.
Ja, Menüs von 1990, so 2000 irgendwie bis 2005 rum.
Hier, hier Ribbon, oder sagen wir eher 2005 rum, Ribbon-Bar-Geschiss und sonst was.
Und jetzt hier das Neueste halt, dieses minimalistische Metro-Zeugs da.
In diesem Hamburger-Menü.
Übrigens, das nennt sich Hamburger-Menü, wer das noch nicht gehört hat.
Ähm, weil das aussieht wie ein Hamburger.
Könnt ihr lachen, das Ding heißt wirklich Hamburger-Menü.
Weiß auch nicht, wem da langweilig war.
So, und das erinnert Microsoft jetzt.
Und, wir können uns, wir können mal ein Beispiel ansehen.
Und gucken, gucken, ob es hier ein gutes, gute Demo gab.
Ja, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja gut, 3D juckt mich jetzt nicht.
Ne, das, äh, der feiert sich nur ein bisschen ab.
Die hatten ein ganz gutes, ganz gutes Demo-Video von ihrer Bildkonferenz.
Was?
Wuh!
Das Video meine ich übrigens.
Oder meine ich das?
Ne.
Oh Mann, dass es einem Microsoft auch so schwierig macht.
Also es gab ein Video, wo sie das neue Design gezeigt haben.
Ähm, das da.
Und das war richtig cool.
Mit dieser Demo-Anwendung, die sie hier gezeigt haben.
Ich muss jetzt mal die letzte Version davon angucken.
Alter, Microsoft-Präsentation.
Ja, also man sieht es hier schon.
Das ist das, was sie hier gezeigt haben.
Ja, das ist das, was sie hier gezeigt haben.
dass es hier im Hintergrund durchschimmert, aber
immer noch darauf geachtet wird, dass da
Kontrast dazu stimmt,
dass die Animationen
sinnvoll eingebaut werden,
dass dann quasi Wartezeiten nicht mehr so lang vorkommen
und sowas. Also da hat Microsoft was wirklich
Gutes gebaut. Und sprich,
die Anwendungen werden dann, hoffe ich,
alle angepasst, die
dabei sind. Paint fliegt ja eh raus.
Es gibt jetzt ja nur noch
Paint 3D, was gar nicht
aufgeht, weil kein Bock und so.
Gut.
Jetzt habe ich mich auch nochmal dazu ausgelassen.
Was ist denn Adobe
Voco?
Schon nie gehört.
Sagt mir nix jetzt.
Hm.
Gut.
Dann machen wir an der Stelle jetzt
Schluss. Spontane Sache.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es trotzdem gefallen.
Ja, wir sind schon fertig mit Ubuntu Beta.
Hat nicht funktioniert, wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe.
Und dann sehen wir uns das nächste Mal.
Macht's gut.
Bis dann. Tschüss.